when you guys were growing up did you
guys have like internalized racism with
your own asian-ness this is really
stupid when I was younger I didn't think
being Filipino was cool but all the
break dancers are Filipinos what city
did you grow up in at that time L.A
native what part of L.A though that
matters
that's cool that's like Filipino did you
want to be Armenian or what nope I
wanted to be Japanese so Japanese oh
it's our generation bro that's why
because all the Filipinos were the cool
Asians when we were growing up Japanese
and Koreans in my high school they were
cool and swaggy there was hella
Filipinos but I just felt like they were
just like they were completely swagless
that's crazy that's like the opposite
all the Filipinos dressed as best they
were into the coolest Fashions they are
kind of swaggy now I think we've like
got in our Renaissance back then Asian
girls are late to bloom when people be
like whatever Asian are you I'd be like
yeah I was in ABG for sure yeah you
don't look like an ABG at all
ABG
thank you